tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovi
video sono fa vigente oggi siamo subito
epico perché siamo su un altro james
variamente una sorta di sito web che
crea gli hunger games minarla in modo
scritto e oggi assisterete la più grande
battaglia della storia di hunger games
siete pronti ad assistere più grandi
hunger games che il mondo abbia mai
visto
per il distretto 1 taylor cui voldemort
per il distretto 2 pari poi è quello
giapponese distretto 3 set mario è miley
cyrus si stretto 4 più di pai e ai
alberghi stretto 5 maurizio costanzo ed
lander me per il distretto 6 stage e i
capelli di stage non ci sta ha provato a
metterli in un personaggio solo però non
ci stavano a radio messi stacca per il
distretto 7 fa vj e justin bieber
dobbiamo fare il culo strisce a tutti
quanti per il distretto 8 non jack and
clubs distretto 9 l
zlatan ibrahimovic distretto 10 jake e
papà distretto 11 andrea diprè è mica è
infine per il distretto 12 dylan o'brian
papà francesco
sono i concorrenti dei 777 hunger games
questi sono i nostri giovani tributi non
tutti i giovani scusata parte il 777
esimi hunger games che i giochi abbiano
inizio da kia ragazzi siamo partiti i
tributi stanno sul piedistallo mentre il
corno suona perfetto quindi siamo
partiti con gli anni organi jake corre
via perfetto che jake è già scappato per
francesco occorre via rasim iver trova
uno zaino pieno di esplosivo bravissimo
justin nicchia che abbiamo già visto e
lee cyrus corre via perfetto l fa
colpisce classici con una spada e la
madonna clapis e ci ha colpito
fantastico ma pj e stars si contendono
uno zaino pro papi 6 rinuncia e si
ritira perche ha vinto falsata di
ibrahimovic e ferisce a morte i capelli
di stage e li lascia morire come poveri
capelli di stage lui e giapponese che
cazzo quello giapponese ha trovato uno
zaino pieno di esplosivo anche lui cioè
l'esplosivo vince il giappone mica corre
via fa vj corazzate pareva non sa che
corre via che tema ricorre via più di fi
corre via dei los mister colpisce
maurizio costanzo mentre era girato di
schiena fantan dove lo ha colpito al
collo milano
scappa perfetto renderman trova una
spada fantastico shia labeouf corre via
con una torcia e alcune corde andrea
diprè rompe il naso di volte il naso di
voldemort e quale naso hai visto a volte
andrea diprè l'unico uomo in grado di
rompere il naso a voldemort harry potter
prende un sacco di coltelli del lancio
fantastico questa prima manche vale
tutto il video trimmer anche perché ha
cambiato non evolvono limmer pesca e
voldemort pesc apcat mario muore di fame
papi jj e falli j
cacciano gli altri tributi a massimo
insieme abbiamo fatto un'alleanza caso
io j che mio padre justin bieber si
camuffa dentro tratto c'è scritto air
self perché hanno preso justin bieber
per una donna che cazzo di problemi che
cos'è papà francesco scappa da stage e
quello giapponese prova a pescare con un
tridente sono arrivati i tributi morti
ragazze i primi quattro a morire in
questa manche sono clapis i capelli di
stage maurizio costanzo hackett mario mi
dispiace ragazzi mi dispiace molto per i
capelli di stage che promettevano bene
ma dai ragazzi continuiamo perché mi
sembra sta andando molto bene notte uno
a cui saranno per la prima notte
fantastica sting bieber non riesce a
convincere papà francesco a non
ucciderla ma è un maschio justin bieber
papà francesco di alla clemenza justin
la prego questa è l'unica strada per la
pace papi jake antichi allegra mesi papa
cantique tranquillo sei solo a degli
hunger games quello giapponese
respingere harry potter voldemort e
stage via dal suo focolare più di pius
renderman si corrono in co anno si
vengono incontro e decidono di rifare
una tregua per la notte perfetto miley
cyrus cura le ferite di challant fa vj
attenzione quali j implora dylan o'brien
di ucciderlo fini sta implorando di ryan
di uccidermi lui rifiuta lasciando vivo
fa vj ma perché è meglio così magari mi
mela mi recupero non c'è chi implora pd
poi di ucciderlo ma lui rifiuta
lasciandolo ciak vivo quello giapponese
ascolta lander man e dylan o'brien
parlare in lontananza perché quello
giapponese è molto smart taylor swift e
miley cyrus minacciano un doppio
suicidio che però fallisce quindi
muoiono
ok l trova una caverna te pareva
contro zlatan ibrahimovic e riceve il
cibo fresco da uno sponsor
tanto lo sappiamo tutti che il paris
saint germain che sgancia il biglietto
shia labeouf e ricevere spray che cazzo
fa vj prende i fiori papà francesco
saija la brooks su che prende
l'esplosivo ma io che cazzo faccio
prende i fiori ma mi sembra giusto
justin bieber è morto fantastico
complice sonda solo el'orso miley cyrus
harry potter sono morti ma da chi
genocidi o secondo me vince quello
giapponese che papi j e più di ply
parlano dei tributi ancora in vita fa vj
e voldemort si stringono la mano è ma
perché lui vuole il naso zio non ti non
ci cadere in così facilmente
non lo sa che lascia che è quello
giapponese entri nel suo rifugio giorno
tre ragazzi ci siano fa vj si rompe la
caviglia scappando via da papà francesco
bravo continua a raccogliere i fiori ma
ti aspetta un pugno renderman jake
voldemort l'oncia che ibrahimovic
cacciano gli altri tribù bastardi sono
messi insieme
cade in un precipizio e muore facciamo
tutti una preghiera per scegliere quello
giapponese strangola slider man con una
fune
porca vacca fa vj voldemort è mica
cantano allegramente una canzone insieme
insomma sembrava andrà di prelancio un
coltello nel petto dj caso ha ucciso j
papà francesco pensa alla vittoria si
aspetta e spera più di pai uccide papi j
ben tornano mia mentre raggirato hai
ucciso mio padre
bene è andata così ragazzi mi dispiace
il giorno 4 quello giapponese si
nascondano i cespugli ci mancava quello
l fa vj andrea diprè iniziano a
combattere ma fa vj corre via mentre l
uccide andrea di tre io sopravvivo
scappando non si sa perché taj prega
papà francesco di ucciderlo ma lei
rifiuta perché anche papà francesco e
una donna segretamente l'ulss ostache
vivo zlatan ibrahimovic ci pensa a casa
ti stavi bene al paris saint germain
sono morti lander medgate papi j andrea
diprè ragazzi se alla fine è più o meno
quasi mi sono rimasti allora voldemort e
quello giapponese più di buy stage io
nonno ciak l ibrahimovic mica dylan
o'brien e papà francesco
cioè non avrei mai pensato in vita mia
che potessero rimanere questi prove mica
ricevere pareri xfactor che li manda le
medicine papà francesco da fuoco a dylan
o'brien con una molotov
ok quindi fai uccide fa vj mentre prova
a correre
hai ucciso mio padre hai ucciso anche
molto gentile grazie mille a ok la
cornucopia che sarebbe la zona centrale
è stata riempita di cibo l decide di non
andare al vii al fisco sarebbe quando
rifornimenti in mezzo e le decide di non
andarci voldemort e più di pai
combattono per un pezzo di carne ma
voldemort cede corre via quello
giapponese uccide papà francesco con una
falce ma li aspetta un pulmino siamo
quasi alla fine son rimasti in
pochissimi quello giapponese si auto
colpisce perché sono morti allora diano
avrai annuncia che fa vj papà francesco
zlatan ibrahimovic ma morti tutti quello
giapponese spara un dardo avvelenato nel
collo di stage uccidendo lentamente mi
dispiace stage hai raggiunto i tuoi
capelli in paradiso quello giapponese
stalker ha più di fi
l mangia delle bacche tosca l non mi
puoi morire così l non mi puoi morire
così non tutti sono morti mica e dell ma
affanculo sono rimasti voldemort quello
giapponese è più di pai voldemort e
quello giapponese si raccontano le sue
storie l'un l'altro certo tanto ci
mancano solo alla fine di pai e sveglio
dagli incubi
stiamo per arrivare alla fine ragazzi a
voldemort prova a salire su un albero ma
cade su quello giapponese morendo
insieme
sono morti bordo è morto e quello
giapponese non ci credo più di pai vinse
il 777 hunger games e che le bravo più
di complimenti
dato che hai ucciso sia me che mio padre
almeno che vince gli hunger games almeno
quello è quindi ragazzi 777.000 games
finiscono qua concludo qui il video
spero che vi sia piaciuto perché è un
qualcosa di un pò diverso che non ho mai
fatto del genere
spero che vi sia piaciuto il video come
sento se vi è piaciuto lasciato come è
un mi piace non mi piace per il naso di
voldemort che ci ha lasciati subito e
per i capelli di stark sono resi
disponibili scindiamo il prossimo vito
bella ragazzi